um you know the covet crisis the war in
in Ukraine has put huge pressures on the
finances of governments uh worldwide how
worried are you about debt
sustainability
well look it's completely separate
what's happening to the world's
developing economies and low-income
Emerging Markets which is the World Bank
and IMF Center in a horrible situation
they had a hard time in the pandemic
many of them are in default or on the
cusp of default and it's a dire
situation the
Global systemic part impact of it is
less it's not making the news here I'm
surprised people aren't talking about it
every day because if you look at the
number of people who are affected by
this people are too busy talking about
the IRA
Q so but I'm actually having just said
that I will leave it to other speakers
to pick up on it but I would say as far
as everybody else goes the 300 trillion
dollar questions what's going to happen
to interest rates what's going to happen
to inflation adjusted interest rates
because part of the reason and I think
most of the reason debt inflated so much
and partly the pandemic but also they're
very low interest that's sort of a
reasonable thing to do if the interest
rate's zero and you have a good
investment and you know or you're
fighting a pandemic
uh I don't think you want to be Reckless
but it's pretty reasonable
uh but on the other hand I believe that
we're entering a world where
inflation-adjusted interest rates are
going to be higher over the next decade
I don't try to predict the next year but
over the next decade than they were uh I
I've done
research on this but uh you know I won't
say I know what's going to happen but
they fell incredibly after the financial
crisis I want to say two percent plus
after the financial crisis there's a
little bit of a long-term downward Trend
that would be a tenth of that maybe over
that period so you know there could be
some reversion to me now does that mean
there's going to be a debt spiral no uh
it doesn't
but individual countries firms places
could get into trouble and I want to be
clear not advanced economies don't
default they inflate but uh just having
one thing go wrong is not enough to get
into a debt problem you run into a
problem as a company you know as a
pension fund when you're off kilter in a
few places when you're you know caught
uh well I don't know can I say this with
your pants down
um
that's when you run that's when you run
into trouble and if so if we have a deep
recession
well a significant recession or some
country does and the interest rates stay
high that
two things I mean even that might not be
enough but that's when you really start
to worry not just about the country debt
but about firms in your country so check
give us just sort of the other the third
you know you mentioned two things the
third ingredient that they continue
Emerging Markets it's commodity prices
that's the classic Trio that Emerging
Markets have a problem there their main
export goes down they're in recession
and the U.S raised its interest rates
it's a big complex world so exactly what
the problems would be we saw the pension
problems in the UK which nobody expected
and that was kind of solved but who
knows for example in Japan uh which is
considered the second safest country in
the world after the us but they haven't
had interest rates go up in decades what
if and I'm not talking just about the
Japanese government but there's
something in the system that we all
should know but none of us know that you
see when it happens that's just example
so I'm going to come back to the UK in
just a second but I wanted to go here um
you know to a world Bank perspective
um with Mr van thrusenberg which is
let's pick up on sort of Emerging
Markets I mean how close would you say
what's your estimate how close we are to
are we to a sovereign debt crisis
well I I would like to pick up where
also a Kenneth about you need to
differentiate people what kind of
developing countries you're dealing with
we have the poorest countries they are
what we call Ida that is the countries
that are benefiting from our fund for
the poorest countries at about
75 countries of which right now 60 are
in debt to stress so uh there you see
this is very complicated and then you
have a series of lower middle income
countries that that are also uh
struggling and most prominently is for
example a country like Sri Lanka and the
problem what we are facing right now is
I let the hipic debt initiative in the
1990s that was to provide comprehensive
debt relief to the poorest countries
that the the composition of that has
radically changed and there is a
continued exposure to multilaterals but
the Paris Club creditors are no longer
very important in fact if you look at
the case of Zambia that needs desperate
debt relief their Periscope is barely 10
but 80 is towards China
so the non-paris club creditors have
become very important and in addition
also uh commercial or uh bond
that is is very important in the time 20
25 years ago when we were dealing with
it those type of debts were usually in
Hopeless arrears and they were just uh
eradicated by a buyback and and was
solved now these are Euro bonds that are
being served and they need to be worked
out and that is very very difficult and
what we are seeing is to get the
difficulties to get the participation of
this but just to emphasize this so
you're in debt to stress you want to
restructure
you are not succeeding and I'm just
again the example of Zambia Zambia is
now in second year in trying to get an a
debt agreement under the common
framework and it is not working and and
so that is uh call a costing politically
but also uh for the social tensions that
uh these expenditures for educational
Health have to take place and so these
are some of the uh challenges that
countries have to face and and Alaska is
we should not forget also that there is
an increasing number of what we call
fragile States
and they have increasing but because
they are in conflict of that and so on
top of of the problems they have the
debt problem and have no access on this
so that is where what we are seeing so
you've raised a number of topics that I
want to pick up I just want to uh ask
you what one quick follow-up which is
also according to the World Bank there's
a bigger proportion of poor Nations debt
that is owed to private lenders in
countries and you mentioned China in
another concept of China India Saudi UAE
so and and I think the World Bank says
that this trend spreads the risk but it
also makes it harder for for countries
to restructure their debt talk a little
bit about that because I think it's
important in the context of what's going
to come later well I think it comes back
to
um two issues that sustainability and
transparency when we did the debt relief
uh in the 90s and then it was creeped
off by the Glen Eagle agreement where
the write-off it gave a new possibility
of countries do go ahead but it was also
a temptation to get into a known
traditional creditors again because the
Paris Club creditors would then
basically go on Grant bases and would no
longer engage in in big lending
operations so they went so it it bought
them a degree of freedom to to issue a
bond or uh or go to other non-paris club
creditors but very often those
conditions were not revealed and it is
not difficult to issue at 12 percent the
Euro Bond but the the cost will be
enormous and that means that the debt
sustainability was never really
integrated into the budget nor were
worth was there the transparency in the
budget that you could see
to whom you actually were owing the new
debts and this is a problem so I I think
if we ever want to go making progress
you will need to have radical uh
transparency that everything is
published including the terms because uh
let parliaments discuss that what a
government wants to do but not to be
surprised in hindsight that some side
deals were made and that have
contributed to the death crisis okay so
I if we can I'd like to come back to
this transparency issue I'd like to go
to the minister so so far most of the
debt issues that we've seen are
concentrated in poorer Nations but we
have seen a civil unrest and sort of
pressure points even in
um in bigger economies more advanced
more advanced developing economies such
as Brazil obviously we saw what happened
earlier this month so how concerned are
you that these pressures will will
spread to sort of middle middle income
Emerging Market Nations
well thank you of thank you for the
invitation to be this panel uh it is a
very good company uh but let me uh let
me start by by saying that there are
middle-income countries with problems I
mean the World Bank will uh will clearly
uh point that out I mean perhaps a lower
proportion than low income country but
there are there are several
middle-income countries and the
Milwaukee countries are also facing uh
you know at least two other issues
um the the first one is the issue that
can already mentioned the higher
interest rates where which actually last
year uh we say also risk margins were
very high so the availability of
financing
came down significantly uh so the uh so
the refund even the refinancing all that
has become more difficult and more
costly let's say uh so the the digital
financing uh continues to be uh quite
important on top let's say of that so I
think that's a first point that I want
to make I mean whether the uh and then
we of course say we can talk later about
the the things that have already been
mentioned about the uh the uh the
difficulty of the current context uh in
terms of the institutions and what sort
of Institutions
or short-term solution uh we will need
but let me perhaps I point out in that
regard uh that the uh there is only uh
you know a strictly speaking only one
framework which is the the the common
framework for that treatment for low
income countries and very few countries
have used it
and then even in those countries even
the the debt restructuring mechanism
that or that suspension and
adopted before that a very few private
creators participated so there's a huge
institutional uh lack of or lack of
institutional arrangements to manage
that issues I want to now I mean one of
the problems of high debts for countries
is of course that your the fiscal space
that countries have are much more
limited than in the past even for
example in my country which is is
probably not a a considered any level
restructuring but but we we do have high
levels of debt by historical standards
56 56 yeah it's 50 if you know people
our Target is 55 and we're two or three
percentage Point depending on the month
above that Target so so we do have high
levels of debt and that reduces the
fiscal space so perhaps in answer to
your question when you have several rest
on have to respond to it you know you
may have limitations instances Your
Capacity your physical capacity to
respond and that's certainly a constrain
us as generally a broader constraint on
the on the resources that you have for
social proactive social policies
great okay so I want to turn to the uh
Shadow Chancellor so
the UK was in the news I mean Professor
ragoff mentioned it obviously and and to
a certain extent um you can say we saw
the return of kind of Bond vigilantes in
in a way to the markets that they saw
um that they punished for being uh
governments that they punished for
seeing as fiscally unwise so in the UK
face this basically pushing up borrowing
costs
um you know to uncomfortable levels
um
you know maybe you can talk a little bit
about the UK situation but in general do
you think we reached some sort of a
turning point between
um sort of you know investors and
government
will focus on uh on on debt and the
borrowing costs are going up globally as
Ken's already uh sets out but
it is for what happened in the UK last
September it was the fault of the
government who announced 45 billion
pounds of unfunded tax cuts and then
went on the television and said there's
more to come uh with no plan of How It's
a grown the economy or how you would
Finance those those cuts and look those
those tax cards and what you saw was in
pretty short order uh robust Market
response so the pounds fell by 10
against the dollar to uh close to parity
uh borrowing costs so the government
increased by 10 mortgage costs which are
hugely important in in the UK because
most people have short-term two-year or
five-year mortgages four million
households in Britain this year will be
renewing a mortgage and so mortgage
costs have a huge impact on uh on
domestic demand and 40 percent of
mortgage products we've just withdrawn
in a matter of a few days because
mortgage companies didn't know how to
price that mortgage lending and then as
as Ken mentioned we had the problem
which I think
absolutely no one I don't think foresaw
of liability driven Investments That
Pension funds were investing in that
were highly leveraged uh and uh and and
highly invested in in government bonds
and as the value of those bonds fell the
collateral calls came in which meant the
bonds had to be solved which then put
further downward pressure on uh on on
bond prices and the bank of England who
had just announced that they were going
to embark on quantitative tightening had
to step in with a big package of um of
of liquidity for the the Pension funds
to to use so it looked like you had you
know the government with the foot on the
accelerator with these tax cuts the bank
of England tightening policy both with
quantitative tightening and increases in
interest rates but then being forced in
this position
um of having to offer further liquidity
just a couple of other things I'd say
about the situation the UK got in I
don't think it was just the decisions to
cut taxes it was the sort of the the
run-up to that so-called mini Budget on
September the 23rd and I think this is
really important in terms of lessons for
others as well Economic Institutions are
incredibly important and undermining
those institutions that give investors
confidence is very dangerous so in the
run-up to that mini budget we had a
leadership contest in the conservative
party a governing party over the summer
where there was undermining of the
Central Bank of the bank of England you
then had the new Chancellor coming in
and the UK had four chancellors last
year
um but the new Chancellor quasi-quarting
came in in September and one of his
first acts was to sack the respected
permanent secretary at the treasury and
then with that mini Budget on the 23rd
of um September when you should have had
a forecast both for the economy and for
government finances for the from the
office for Budget responsibility that
wasn't allowed to be published even
though it was available which just gave
this impression that the government had
something to hide and wasn't operating
within the Frameworks that had existed
in the UK in terms of the bank of
England since 1998 and in terms of the
office of budget responsibility since
2010 and those things combined with the
huge unfunded nature of the tax cuts got
you know we're not a low-income country
we're not a middle-income country we're
in the G7 and we got into huge
difficulties and I think that is less
than a lesson for for any country that
wants to embark on those sorts of
policies without explaining and I'd say
how I started not the Bond vigilantes
thought investors looked at the UK and
the governor of the bank of England said
last week Andrew Bailey said last week
that there's still a hangover effect
from what happened in September with
question marks being put over the UK as
a place to invest now look I'm the
opposition party I want to turn that
around or maybe come on to a bit of that
but that's what happened so yeah in
September and indeed I mean I think the
markets that that was um I was trying to
be a bit more diplomatic but you know
the shadow Chancellor here I think you
know you said it you said it as you
think it but you know clearly the the
markets punished the government there's
no and if I could just push you a little
bit more because of course
Marcus recovered but um you know the UK
economy is still lagging you know uh and
and worries about growth are leading a
lot of investors to limit their Holdings
um uh this is both of the pound and of
British debt
um and so you know can you give us a
sense of how your government your party
if in government would would fix things
so the first thing and the lesson from
September is that any economic policy
has to be built on on a rock of Economic
and fiscal responsibility uh and that
that has to come before anything else
but it's also obvious and you make this
point that the UK needs a serious plan
for economic growth because in
productivity and in growth terms and
numbers that um were published today
about foreign direct investment shows
that the UK has been missing out the
last decade uh or so compared to our
nearest neighbors and our competitors
um as well and look the reason that KIA
stama the leader of the opposition um in
the UK and myself are here this week is
to send a message that you know at the
next election where at the moment
laborer are have a strong lead in the
opinion polls that the British economy
will be open for business again that we
want to work with business and partner
with business to get that growth and
productivity back in the UK okay economy
you know part of that is sorting out
some of the mess of the the brexit deal
um of of a couple of years ago which has
seen our exports uh fallen off and jobs
move um abroad in many cases
um it's uh the green Prosperity plan
that uh Kiera and I have been setting
out because the UK has got every reason
to think that we could be leaders in
some of these industries of the future
our great universities our industrial
Heritage our our geography but at the
moment we're falling behind both the US
and of course the announcement this week
by uh by Ursula vondelion to the to the
EU as well when it comes to supporting
investment in those green industries of
the future but an incoming labor
government wants to work with in
partnership with business to secure the
investment the jobs that is needed to
turn around the poor economic
performance you know not just since the
brexit vote in 2016 but really now for
just over a decade Okay so so that's why
the labor party you you are here in
Dallas is part of that effort that's why
we are here because you know somebody
has got to be an ambassador for for
Britain and the Prime Minister and
Chancellor of my country are not here uh
labor I hope to form the next government
and so we think it's really important to
be here talking to business and
investors about our plans for the future
thank you Professor
um
quantitative tightening just just a
little bit in how it fits in this
equation
um and the impact that it'll have this
year
um you know central banks obviously have
had a huge uh presence over the past
year um in the world's biggest Bond
markets
um and basically tightening policy at
the same time the bond sales were rising
and all of this is adding to sort of
upward pressure on borrowing costs um I
mean to what does this all add up to to
debt sustainability you know what what
are the vulnerabilities here let me
start by seconding uh you made many
important points but one in particular
about Central Bank Independence and I
think whatever was true 40 years ago in
this day and age undermining Central
Bank Independence is suicide that's been
an incredibly effective device for uh
giving confidence in so many ways not
just with the inflation rate but I'd
Almost Say with institutional integrity
and it's I I think it's a mistake to try
to attack central banks and you know
turkey has fired more Central Bank
medicine maybe the same number shout out
as chancellors
so uh
quantitative tightenings particularly
significant in your the Eurozone so if I
can talk about that
where it the quantitative easing had a
very important element to where the
European Central Bank is the most
important euro-wide institution or it
wasn't at one time and it has the fiscal
capacity to do big things quickly and I
think it did a lot to prop up periphery
Southern Country debt during the crisis
but it sold it on the idea that we're
fighting deflation and we have to raise
prices
and I don't think they really thought
that but it's sold that way so it's very
hard in this other direction where
interest rates are going up and Italy's
interest rates seem to go up uh you know
more than proportionally to how much
Germany's interest rates go up and it's
clear that if you just pulled the rug
out from onto this Italy's rates would
go up a lot more and I think the ECB has
done a very good job in trying the
communications of this tightrope but
it's very hard so they say they have
another way of doing it and
say but I think I think elsewhere it's
not such a big deal except in Japan
where they've they did a much more
extreme policy where many of you may
know they they fix not just the policy
rate as the FED does and many other
Central picks they fix the 10-year right
now that worked when interest rates
seemed like they really ought to be
negative in Japan and so people accepted
it but now that there's upward pressure
on real rates which I already mentioned
and inflation everywhere even Japan
that really is hard for them to back on
up
yeah yeah we've it's been in the news
just over the past few days a lot what's
been happening in Japan I wanted to come
back to China because you had mentioned
it just um just just in your remarks
before so I think in December um China
which of course is the largest uh
sovereign debt creditor um agreed with
the IMF to participate in um in a global
sovereign debt Roundtable
um you know about death release other
Solutions what role does China play Then
in
in everything we've been talking about
what should they do what should China
take up uh sort of the mantle to do well
I think we need to keep this in a
perspective we are in a transition
period where you know we were in a
paradigm that you deal with uh the Paris
Club the traditional creditors the
multilateral creditors and this has now
been changing so uh also in the previous
Workout non-paris Club creditors didn't
pay an insignificant role now they are
paying a very significant role and that
is I think the challenge to to bring the
uh these creditors into this process of
dialogue and it is not only China India
is an important creditor Saudi Arabia
some of the Arabs in in Indonesia and
they need all to be in there and
this has been a challenging uh and I
think that was also a fun mental idea of
the common framework of how you think
differently of this and in the last I
would say two years we have seen
limitations but of of the common
framework the common framework is
actually extremely important to bring
everybody around but it has been also
very difficult and challenging to get
them to to the agreements that are
necessary and also they're on a timely
basis so
at the uh six plus one this is a meeting
that the Prime Minister of China the
kitchen
does with the six International
organizations including the IMF and the
World Bank we agreed to have on this
round table that is co-chaired by the
IMF the world bank and then the G20
presidency so that is in this year
[Music]
India and we will start at the deputies
level the first discussion next month at
the G20 meeting in in India and then
probably in in April May and with the
finance ministers and and really it is
about
fostering the dialogue first of all what
needs to be done and then actually
um see how we can help these countries
work out because it's very clear they
take also a case of of Sri Lanka
the problem is that there is not that
work out right now and the country
desperately needs a lot of financing and
and that is not assured so that is why
it is uh urgent I would actually say one
last reflection maybe also with the
common framework as I had done the hip
initiative with with the IMF what we did
in in the midnight it was come up with a
framework what that sustainability means
and you can criticize whether there's
MPV that to exports or The Debt Service
ratios all the right ones but it was a
very clear spelled out process that you
use first of the Paris Club process you
exhausted it's not necessary we need to
do additional things right now we you
have negotiations where there is not an
established that sustainability
framework so what you see in the
discussions in regard that different
creditors are challenging all the
underlying assumptions or is this really
sustainable take the case of chat now of
course then are you looking at that
sustainability today or are you
projected that in the future how long in
the future and this has been very
complicated in addition we need to think
about that in many of these Frameworks
earlier we were only looking at external
debt and domestic debt has also become
important so this is a very overdue
discussion that will need to be held I
hope also that you get first on the
political things that we need to to
tackle those countries that are in
desperate need for treatment and then we
also in parallel start having this
discussion of our much much clearer
framework against which we then can
Define the level of that relief I mean
just all of you I mean I mean they're a
compelling case for a major new round of
debt relief I don't know if anybody
ah I know for institutions
can I talk about that absolutely and
then I have a question on another
question for you but is there a
compelling case I think you go Case by
case yeah
well no the situation is Case by case in
any case but the lack of Institutions
for deadly negotiations is a major
institutional problem in the world
economy uh I mean all this all the
solutions have been ad hogged the Brady
plan the the relief for poor countries
now the this common framework uh they're
ad hoc that we do need an institution uh
a permanent way of managing these issues
so an international debt fund sorry not
just debt organization yeah well it
could be it could be the IMF as it was
tried in the early part of the century
uh you know it could be the IMF it could
be the United Nations institution but we
did a an Institutional framework where
decisions can be handled uh and of
course I mean the the issue of the the
let's say the the levels of debt and
when they are risky let's say which is
the good work that done by the World
Bank and the MF uh is of course was a
step forward uh but again that that's a
that should be a a framework for for for
something else that is missing in
let me stop that for the time being man
good because I want to ask you something
else which is several countries in Latin
America have including Colombia and
Argentina Ecuador have proposed death
swaps in order to meet climate goals and
your government has as well and
basically under the scheme developing
countries
um basically get their debts canceled or
reduced in exchange for
um sort of commitments that they will
then Finance green projects
um and I think you have suggested it for
the Amazon
um can you give us an update on how that
is proceeding well let me let me
separate issue that relief and the
restructuring from that for of course
but it's an interesting absolutely but
it is the definition swaps or for
climate swaps was institution or the
climate change negotiation not of the
debt issue okay and I think it makes all
of the also
you know a major sense to uh to enhance
significantly and this by the way has to
do with the with you know one basic fact
is that if you want you want to point
out one major issue of inequality in the
world is the contribution to climate
change uh it's all the responsibility of
major responsibilities from developed
countries so developed countries should
actually uh support uh in a significant
way uh you know the you know the climate
change mitigation and climate change
adaptation which is a a major problem
and you know the Dead four nature
therefore climate swaps is one mechanism
among many others that should be part of
that solution together with the 100
000 uh excuse me 100 million dollars
that were promised
as a contribution for the devil
structuring or and
for for excuse me for climate change uh
mitigation in developing courses which
has not been met so so the I think
that's it but don't I don't think that
don't mix them
don't make them I think we're talking
about that in more general not for day
for nature swaps which is a climate
change but it's a topic here so I I it
was an interesting it's an interesting
proposal so that's why I wanted to
know many countries have used it yeah in
the past including Colombia and it
should be you know more widely used
for example for our countries it's a
small thing relative to uh to that our
debt uh is very small but it can be a
major contribution uh to uh our fight
against climate change Professor wanted
to jump in well two two quick things
first on you asked the question about
epic initiative that's when the deaths
were written down and there is a big
problem today with the presence of China
as a creditor it just has to be a part
of it if China doesn't want it then it
can't happen I I don't want to get into
it here but I'm all in favor of giving
developing economies Aid uh I have a
proposal for World carbon Bank to uh
Channel technical expertise and funds to
uh developing economies
to take up another time
but debt for nature swaps I don't favor
I think actually they sound much better
on paper than if you look at them
closely each case is different but it
basically it was the front page of time
the cover of Time magazine in 1988 and
it was I I think by and large their
giveaways to the creditors
it's a good point I mean what they do
this is where the economists in you and
the minister in you sort of uh no no
what they do give you money for a
climation mitigation adaptation it is a
useful instrument for example if let's
say let's take down the the this major
South America initiative which is uh to
preserve the Amazon which is a I get the
largest remaining jungle in the in the
world uh you know which is a major
source of climation mitigation so so I
think it's a world responsibility to
support the Amazon so it's a northern
South American initiative and if the
mechanism I mean they want to do
donations straight uh fine that they
will be they'll take them I will
probably uh you know celebrate but that
if therefore this or therefore climate
uh
swap that like 10 percent of the Amazon
in Colombia but you know
that is done by a foreign country no no
no no no no no no no I I would not give
a centimeter of the Amazon to any
foreign country uh I mean for sure
no no but but I mean let's let's put it
this way the deforestation
of the Amazon and is the major
contribution of Latin America certainly
of my country uh to climate change is an
objective that should be promoted and
then how that is financed uh is uh is a
is a important I want to do the shutter
tensor in five minutes
giving money to Columbia to preserve the
Amazon great idea that for nature swipes
the problem is that the debt that
doesn't get taken away gets bit up in
value that's been the problem so you're
giving money to all the people who
didn't swap they're done transfers are
better yes
okay all right the minister will be
outside accepting donations uh after
this match um since I was going to use
another example like NHS or education or
whatever I'll use client energy
transition which is what are the
implications right for of a debt
Mountain
um you know in for pressing priorities
that any government has that you that
your government would have including for
energy transition projects yeah well
look I think the investors can see the
difference between
um unfunded tax cuts
um and investment in infrastructure that
yields a long-term um return and uh but
obviously what happened in September in
the UK does make it harder to make that
that case but you know the UK like other
countries around the world have to play
their part and it's all well and good
preaching and lecturing other countries
what they must do around the world but
we've got to get our own house in order
and of course course to meet the climate
emergency which is a moral obligation
but also in the UK because it is the way
to grow the economy
um the the jobs of the future in those
Industries carbon capture uh green
hydrogen
Etc that is where future jobs and
prosperity is going to come from but
what you're seeing in countries around
the world that are taking this seriously
it is through a partnership with
government and business but the other
thing I would say this is just not just
about money at every business that I
speak to who wants to invest says you've
got to sort out the plan and you've got
to sort out the regulation you've got to
sort out the good connections you know
the role of government isn't just to
provide money it's also to provide the
framework of the long-term stability to
encourage that in investment but I think
the investors and everyone can see the
difference between short-term Sugar Rush
plans for growth and the long-term
investment that is needed to kick-start
Industries in the econ anime okay we
have about five minutes for questions
please
hello uh hirany schmur from Japan snake
I'm Professor
you mentioned Japan several times so I
must ask this
um so should Bank of Japan abandon its
yield curve control policy and what will
happen if it does abandon its policy
and it's
High public debt level adding or feeling
upward pressure on interest rates where
will that happen
thank you try to make a careful answer
to this to not cause a crash in the end
um so it makes sense to try to at this
point to try to keep it going as long as
you can because the accident's not going
to be pretty if there does have to be a
dramatic accident as far as Japan's debt
which is 260 percent of GDP about half
of which is basically one day debt I
mean I think it's manageable it sounds
infinite but I think it's manageable
there may be some inflation but the
problem is when your debt's that high
you don't necessarily have a lot of
fiscal space we heard that earlier to
deal with anything else so if a problem
arose because there's a UK type pension
the pension type problem buried
somewhere in the financial system that
nobody knew then there's less resources
to wrap around that that's that's really
the risk of having such a high debt but
you know the sang Japan Japanese
interest rates would go up famously
called the Widow mix per trade so I'm
aware of that Minister did you wanted to
add anything on this you said you want
to talk about the ah you you were not
going to talk about this are you okay
yes please
[Music]
how do you think
private sector debt particularly
domestic debt should be handled because
there are complications that which tends
to be held by Pension funds and
insurance
companies and my hunch is that you can't
discriminate
um against the foreign
what have you seen what do you think
should be done
let's get this question as well so then
we can answer and and close yes
sure Council on energy Environmental
water and member of the UN committee for
development policy and an advisor to the
union
presidency a question about uh climate
related
macroeconomic shocks that are only going
to grow over the years now even if a
country of a low-income or middle income
country were being responsible with
their debt uh these this is an
externally imposed uh constraint it's
just not it's not just a fiscal
constraint it just completely messes up
their their macroeconomic situation what
would uh Professor rogoff or Jose
Antonio Campo recommend as a way to
create an insurance cushion for that
kind of vulnerability great well so well
first to you first question and then you
can both jump in on that
well the first question
um I think that we are seated so there
is a uh not an agreed framework often
that workout that involves equally the
domestic debt and the and and the
external that and what we are seeing is
that it is there are huge sensitivities
particularly where you have incipient
Pension funds
um I think what uh what is being tried
and that is usually with the IMF
programs that one tries to to have an
orderly workout in the domestic one but
the domestic that we need also to say
there can be central banks there can be
institutional investors there is also
with business so the someone needs to
see what is the type of that and
particular where local business has to
accept a huge haircut uh what that
actually means for the local economy so
those things will need all to be
evaluated on the external that I think
uh there are the collection action
losses that need more use but also I
think quite frankly
that we have to say within a framework
how you can enforce action and this has
to be debated what you saw was the dssi
the that service uh suspension
initiative it was all voluntary and not
voluntary participation a patient didn't
work well and so what needs to discuss
how we want in the future to have those
kind of workouts but just to concretely
take in the Zambia case but also this is
going to come up in in Sri Lanka if all
these data is don't want to act on this
uh we need to have a serious discussion
about the lending of arrears by
multilateral institutions and we have
been now doing that now for sometimes in
Zambia or very loud on this Zambia will
need a critical financing but I would
then say then run arrears okay we need
to quickly because we need to close
Minister and then no uh on this issue
certainly uh you know actually in the
the most recent International
um you know discussions on the issue of
uh let's say climate change crisis uh I
think this issue of the or for example
well I mean there are all the issues
like for the Caribbean which has already
been subject to a lot of risk associated
uh you know to hurricanes uh that's one
issue but more recently they show of a
specific you know a climate crisis a
crime you know floods for example like
the Pakistan last year or even my
country you know which has a significant
plot
Associated to climate change I think
that the whole economy should create an
instrument a kind of insurance mechanism
for those cases which you know more or
less was in the in the appointed
negotiations in the climate change in
in the cup so I think there has to be a
creative but I think it's a parliament
mechanism uh not necessarily I said it's
actually to to be able to fund the the
cause of a or manage that is those
specific crisis so it has Morris in the
insurance mechanism that the world had
lacks today uh I think different from
the uh from debt as such and last word I
mean I think there are places that are
going to become very difficult to live
because you can't get insurance that's
already true in parts of the United
States and for small island States
there's nowhere to move and uh it's uh
they it's a huge problem and I'm not
sure that any amount of money really is
going to solve that they're going to
need to be adjustments and that's part
of climate change all these uh places
that people suddenly have to move and as
Al Gore has said having all the climate
refugees that's just a piece of it
Shadow Chancellor I didn't give you a
last word did you have a five second
last remark I mean even in the UK we are
seeing the impacts of climate change
with a much more flooding including my
own constituency which we'd never seen
um before and obviously the problems in
some of the developing parts of the
world are even greater and we have to
come together as a global Community to
address these challenges
wonderful all right well thank you very
much to the panelist sorry for running a
few minutes over and thank you to
everyone who listened
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign